if you feel like you're really small
maybe you are I'm dr. Lisa Masterson and
I'm an obstetrician and gynaecologist my
name is doctor Kia Michelle from
comprehensive urology I'm a urologist I
deal with everything women and men as it
involves relationships and sex and
fertility today we're gonna answer
Google's most popular sex questions
it depends them by what you mean by that
so you can certainly have healing on the
outside you can have peeling on the
inside it might be discharge it might be
shedding layers that's something you
definitely want to see a doctor about if
you have that you also want to make sure
that there's no history of diabetes or
not developing diabetes that can be a
reaction to a lotion or so sort of a
toxic irritant but it does need to be
checked out because nobody wants to walk
around with a peeling vagina if the lips
are swollen then that's definitely not a
good thing because you're walking around
with something that's you know
uncomfortable and protruding so the
information can come about because of
trauma vigorous intercourse or
penetration or vigorous even external
rubbing it could be a Barthel insist or
birth --lens abscess those things need
to be drained by a doctor if you're the
vagina or the lips again are swollen
something you need to go see your doctor
about
what happened before the penis started
bleeding if you have an STD that could
be another issue you can kind of break
up the the penis into several different
segments one is the urethra if there's
blood coming out of there then there's
been some trauma to the urethra itself
if the urine itself is bloody you've got
to make sure that there's something more
serious is not happening and then
there's the external penile skin you're
not gonna have too many issues why the
penis is bleeding apart from some form
of trauma sometimes self-inflicted
sometimes with a partner sometimes by a
foreign object
why is my penis small that's one of the
most commonly asked questions that we
have I know every guy has a thing about
their penis and really they want to know
how a woman's gonna react to it turns
out the most men are roughly about the
same size in terms of length which is
about six inches we all see these
pictures in the porn magazines and that
may be outside of normal most men that
fit within that average of roughly about
six inches so if you feel like you're
small you may not be as small as you
think you may be very very much normal
very average like breasts come in
different shapes and sizes so do penises
oh my god women have such issues with
having sex on their period and it may be
their partner some are squeamish some
don't want it to look like a crime scene
after all if that's something you're
comfortable with and your partner is
sure it give me the time where women
have most orgasms because they're well
lubricated they're relaxed all those
hormones are let down and people should
you know welcome that and be good with
it and then put it down a lot of towel
you can still get pregnant so be careful
if you're going to do that you still
need to use some form of protection
that's kind of a judgment call and I
think it's really up to the person you
have to decide what's comfortable for
you and I think that's really the answer
[Music]
for most women have a urinary tract
infection if you have intercourse it
hurts a lot more so wait
there's also called honeymoon cystitis
which is actually a bladder infection
you may get on your honeymoon if you
have your sex for the first time and I
will tell you if I had it you cannot
have sex nothing's that urgent if you
can just give yourself a few days of
antibiotics make sure infection is
completely rid it up you're in a much
much better place any infections you
want to get cleared up before you have
intercourse
I would imagine what you mean by that is
that your hymen a stayed intact and
typically it breaks during intercourse
for the first time but that doesn't
necessarily have to be it's also
possible that the partner was so small
that that didn't occur but that's very
very rare for that to happen the high
mental ring can actually even burst
without intercourse so it doesn't really
matter if that's there or not it's okay
as long as it's not causing you
discomfort okay so you had sex and now
you're peeing blood that's not a good
thing most likely you have a urinary
tract infection which causes a lot of
inflammation inside the bladder go to
your physician very quickly get your
urine analysis in your culture and it's
done and only thereafter take some
antibiotics that should help you quite a
bit you should call your doctor because
there is the plan B that you can take
depending on where you are in your last
menstrual period how many times you've
actually missed a pill it could still be
an important factor and you can actually
do this with your own pills and sort of
double up but call your doctor to have
them tell you how to do it it could just
be from sex sometimes there's a reaction
between the semen and the vaginal fluids
and a lot of times that can cause a
specific odor probably there's an
infection there chlamydia gonorrhea
trichomonas those are the most common
infections that we see in women that
cause these types of changes it could
just be from all that friction going on
down there and it could be something
else it could be that gave you a
bacterial infection so it's just
important to get checked out if you do
have some odor that you're concerned
about that doesn't go away
[Music]
maybe they didn't hit all of your right
buttons everybody has a button and it
may not be a button down there it may be
you know on the face and maybe by the
ear there's so many different factors
that go into being able to achieve a
good orgasm you've been drinking a lot
have you taken any drugs have you done
anything else that can potentially
change your sensuality or your sensation
you just have to keep going at it and
keep experimenting you should feel
something that's the ideas it should be
enjoyable it should be connection if you
don't actually feel anything like say
you put your finger and you don't
actually feel anything you definitely
want to talk to your doctor about that
because maybe there's some nerve damage
or something that's going on that needs
to be corrected thank you so much for
your questions they were absolutely
awesome people need to know you know
what their bodies like and not be afraid
to talk about it to remember while
Google and the Internet are fantastic
resources for so many different things
make sure that the questions that you
have you sit down with the healthcare
professional and you speak with them
it's your diva on or you know your guide
diva on - it's so so important to love
yourself before you invite anybody else
to love you be safe be careful and
understand what your needs are know
about your partner and have fun
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]